yo bootleg podcast special guest here
man his new album la is not safe man la
is not safe out now shout out my [ __ ]
bootleg kev we in this [ __ ] man shout
out to homie stills who produced the
whole thing too man yeah yeah man shout
out to holy produced by steals right
fully produced by him from one to five
[ __ ] we going crazy hey man listen go
get that right now and uh we're gonna
we're gonna have him do what he does all
right this is the second time we had to
do this
yeah man hopefully we get we get it
right this time let's go let's go yeah
we have some sd card malfunctions but
let's go crazy man yellow hill yeah turn
me up a little bit
a bit yeah
[Music]
cold [ __ ] i'm on your neck like a scarf
[ __ ] it was either bangerhood or hit
the park [ __ ] it was either drive a
spaceship or a car [ __ ] blue band and
i'm feeling like a marge [ __ ] yellow
[ __ ] got me feeling like i'm bark [ __ ]
everything is pushed to start [ __ ] it
was either by a spaceship or a car [ __ ]
tupac got me feeling like a pop [ __ ]
west side pika i'm yelling [ __ ] all the
cops the enemy goes getting defeated i'm
yelling [ __ ] all the odds trades up and
they just don't stop this bad [ __ ] on
my job wanna see me to get an issue meet
me up on the block and since i started
making this music all these [ __ ] we
wanted to talk hating on me up in my
city because i'm out here getting this
squad [ __ ] stop [ __ ] it's for your ass
get popped there's two braids a bandana
yellow snoop dogg and pot i chuck the
west side up i'm at the west side cuts
i'm a west side [ __ ] i know some west
side bloods fake homies in disguise i
gotta cut them all off [ __ ] [ __ ]
out here they acting weird they are
brides on god imma thug until the wheels
fall off yo [ __ ] love me imma [ __ ] her
till the heels fall off [ __ ] no remorse
[ __ ] snitching all in court tattoos on
they face but we knowing they some dorks
hey yellow hill to low do the most for
the cheddar cheese bad little [ __ ]
addicted to me methamphetamine hey i'm
just a player with the kango
tell that [ __ ] to go and change clothes
hey we watch pornhub not bang bros i'm
just playing baby i don't watch no bang
bros hey i do the most them [ __ ] all
week i'm getting money [ __ ] i'm from
mgc marvin gains the [ __ ] that's the
click that i claim a [ __ ] really got an
issue then i'm quick with the bang the
semi-automatic bullets they be eating
his brain this yellow hood alok [ __ ]
and i'm going insane any west coast
[ __ ] wanna diss me
[Music]
man they know it's really cracking keep
it ballin full hey big chain westside
money click [ __ ] got a problem then i
hit him with that semi-click hey ak-47
with the m16s [ __ ] got a problem then
i'm all up in their [ __ ] dreams i'm
freddy krueger jason x when it comes to
it all my [ __ ] getting money run a gun
to it used to ride a [ __ ] four now
i'm in the buick i had to lay low [ __ ]
cause the feds knew it hey i'm still
freestyling top dome hit a [ __ ] up with
the pistol that's the hot chrome hottest
young [ __ ] in the city that's in l.a
shout out to debato my [ __ ] do the
damn thing hey
empire on the low had to tell them
little [ __ ] yeah i need the loaf it
was either be a blood or a [ __ ] loaf
but shout the dime moves [ __ ] man
yeah it's the top of the dome this the
top of the stack this is the ti oh my
god
l.a is not safe out right now yellow
hill we going up man off the top of the
donut that's how we do it man that was
crazy man that was crazy go get the ep
shout out to homie steals man yellow
hill boulet cab